angela esta mañana informábamos de que
la situación estaba mucho más tranquila
desde ayer no había nuevos ingresos aquí
a ceuta en esta ciudad autónoma en el
norte de áfrica pero que pertenece a
españa sin embargo hace algunos minutos
nos enteramos de que en el mar apareció
el cuerpo de un migrante fallecido en
esta crisis migratoria que afecta a este
territorio sería el segundo fallecido en
esta crisis que comenzó el lunes pasado
vimos el bote salvavidas un helicóptero
y varios autos de la policía y se
confirmó la triste noticia la otra
preocupación acaso los menores solos hay
cerca de dos mil pero 400 de ellos
solamente están siendo tratados por la
cruz roja que está satisfaciendo sus
necesidades básicas a la espera de que
las comunidades autónomas acepten
algunos de ellos recordemos el
presidente pidió a las comunidades que
reciben al menos a 200 niños no
acompañados pero es son ellas las que
tienen la última palabra en esta crisis
ángela